miss me
yeah I see
one thing
almost nothing easy
[Music]
that is
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
foreign foreign
false
[Music]
I am
alone
foreign
[Music]
ERS podcast in the Dunya the three
Muslims are you guys doing today
alhamdulillah
how are you
alhamdulillah doing good first and
foremost let me ask
um both fried and Angel and everyone in
the chat do you guys hear like some
audio clipping or anything like that any
weird noise
no what I do know is once upon a time I
know used to use wired headphones and
that happened when it talked on his
beard
so maybe it's you growing your beard out
bro
foreign
man
so what's been going on man apparently
some guy named Nick Fuentes and this is
no disrespect but I actually have no
idea who this is so why don't you
Enlighten us bro
um I wish I could to be honest I don't
really know either uh all I know is that
he's he has some very weird opinions um
I've I've heard him been you know he was
called a lot of things I don't want to
say anything uh incorrect I don't want
to call him anything that he's not but
he definitely has some very specific
opinions on Race on religion on politics
and he's not very favored I think in uh
in a lot of communities and
um I think this video will make him
unfavorable in our community as well but
I guess we'll find all inshall then you
can all decide for yourselves sure
should we just jump into it
yeah all right
so this guy's name is um Nick Fuentes
all right here we go
politics is my thing I'm a baby
Christian still but
I want to learn everything just so I
could shut these Muslims mouths
because they're they're all there I
apologize in advance
um for any swear words please you know
if your discretion is advised if you
don't want to listen to that which I
understand click off the Stream
I'll just come across so slimy
like this one guy snico did this
interview with this
Muslim
and the whole thing
the guys just saw like such a weasel
they don't even talk about their own
religion they just attack Christianity
Christianity is the real Faith
Christianity
and it's sacred magisterium is the real
treasury of Revelation and God's wisdom
and so they don't even talk about their
own sad Trade Post religion they just
spend all their time attacking
Christianity I mean isn't that so rich
he goes there and they're sitting on
their pillows and they got their Muslim
library and they talk for an hour and a
half and instead of talking about you
know Islam
they just spend 90 minutes on
Christianity you know it's so funny
because do you guys remember when we
fight when Yumi spoke with siniko one of
the things he mentioned was and we made
a short about it so check out the shorts
he was like Christians say that since
their religion is so attacked that it
must be true because everyone's
attacking it remember when he said that
this is the same exact argument you know
he's like Christianity is the you know
the night religion and Shining Armor and
these demons need to you know attack it
and bring it down because it's the truth
I think it's funny and it's funny
because he spends 15 minutes attacking
Islam and attacking Muslims so it's like
it's so funny but regardless I mean
sneaker used to be a Christian so why
wouldn't they talk about it gives dawah
predominantly to Christians why wouldn't
they talk about it and I find it I just
find that hilarious
um
you can literally see the amount of like
Fury and rage that he has bro yeah yeah
I mean look at this guy completely
emotional bro and you can you can
literally tell like when it comes to
Islam
this might be a hot take but I think
Islam is arguably one of the most
persecuted attacked I guess slandered
religions misrepresented religions today
and not just today bro I think of all
time
absolutely and we did discuss that with
Nico so you guys can go check it out
there inshallah
and that makes sense because their
religion is a trading post religion and
they're Trading Post people I mean even
the guy that's there
it just comes across as so insincere
but that's how they are I mean that
religion literally came up
in a trading post and so these are
scammers these are scammer it's a
scammer religion it's a scammer Merchant
religion
they are selling their religion like
these Egyptians will try to sell tourist
beads at the Great Pyramids
and so the guys rolled around and saying
look I got a National Geographic
magazine for children that says the
Christianity is a pagan holiday yeah
okay that's written some really rigorous
stuff not only that
but at the same time
like I said
not even going to talk about Islam
and how ridiculous all that is
we're going to spend the whole hour and
a half just attacking Christianity
I don't think a real religion I don't
think a real religion does the real
religion
if that were the real religion it would
just speak about itself speak for itself
it wouldn't go and talk about you know
the other thing they didn't spend the
whole hour attacking Judaism they didn't
spend the whole hour attacking Buddhism
they didn't spend the whole hour
attacking Hinduism they spent an hour
and a half attacking Christianity with
these third grade arguments it's I find
it so funny because a lot of these third
grade arguments Christians can't really
deal with them why did Jesus say and
this is why young Don may Allah bless
and guide him this is why he he dropped
the Trinity and became a Unitarian
because Jesus says in the Bible the only
true God is the father so these are
things Christians do struggle with
believe it or not and it's it's funny
that he isn't really making an argument
of his own he just kind of ish talking
if we're being honest yeah bro you get
what I mean like that's like me being
like bro you got a third grade set up
with that green screen here you're
probably in your dungeon instead of just
getting an actual setup but there's no
point of talking about that why don't we
use real arguments intellectual
arguments you're gonna talk talk about
insincere what is your evidence does he
just seem insincere because based on
that I could say oh anyone seems
insincere where's the evidence for that
and on top of that apparently this is
what I know from snico he's a friend of
Nick Fuentes so perhaps there could be
an emotional attachment to his friend
being Christian with him and now all of
a sudden he feels betrayal he feels like
maybe sneak was moving on to something
else I know me and Angel definitely
experienced that in the past with a
friend as well yeah yeah that's a great
Point that's that's very Humane a very
humane way of looking at it
I want to go back just a little bit
because there's something there's
another point I want to make slit my
mind would you speak about itself speak
for itself it wouldn't go and talk about
you know the other thing they didn't
spend the whole hour attacking Judaism
oh yeah I remember now um listen this is
very easily addressed the only two
religions that call people to come
accept their way of life is Islam
and Christianity the Judaism is an
ethnocentric religion Hinduism sequelism
for the most part they're they're like
nationalistic religions geographical
religions just one area Buddhism isn't
really a religion it's more just a way
of life doesn't really deal with the
idea of God are the only two that call
people
to believe it that's why they're two of
the biggest religions in the world well
predominantly why so I mean it's pretty
clear as to why they would say this is
the only other one people speak about
let's refute that and then people can
come you know see the beauty of Islam
you don't need to man it's not all he
does they have many videos yes we're
feeding Christianity and proving snap
many dies but of course you know this
guy's gonna focus on this one little
Point even those Nico himself used to be
a Christian so it makes the utmost sense
that they would discuss this
um
bro we've only gotten like not even a
minute in while we're watching this
why are we even giving this guy any
a platform are we giving him any
attention why are we putting him on like
this
what's the point
to educate him and the authors on why
he's wrong how to deal with these
arguments or the fact that they're not
arguments to begin with they're just
random claims that some white kid is is
you know spouting sitting in front of a
green screen behind the camera they'll
be a response let me ask you a real
question do you really think that we're
going to educate
this guy
maybe maybe not you don't know to your
try I would love to talk to Nick Fuentes
and if we don't educate him then we'll
educate somebody I'm sure there's lots
of people in here inshallah that will
benefit from it oh easy bro I could tell
there's gonna be a lot of Nick Fuentes
viewers coming to this video and each
other maybe you're learning a thing or
two
Insha'Allah
didn't spend the whole hour attacking
Buddhism they didn't spend the whole
hour attacking Hinduism they spent an
hour and a half attacking Christianity
with these third grade arguments
well in the Bible it says this here and
then over here it said this
[Laughter]
they've been good
Printing and reproducing the Bible for
two thousand years you're the first one
to notice it
you're the first one to notice it all
these serious I mean you just and here's
the thing I mean Muslims are really into
pointing out the so-called
contradictions in the Bible here we go
Muslims are really into that and setting
aside how silly that is as a form of
as a form of argument
for a lot of reasons
um
at the start they say yo look this says
this but this says this Christianity
debunked you know it's Nico sitting
there and goes wow well there it is just
like you said and it's like hang on a
minute let's just use some common sense
let's just let's say you know nothing
about Christianity and all these things
have explanations of course uh what what
of course all these things have
explanations of course we have to be
right we can't possibly be wrong it's
not something like that I can fathom you
notice that throughout this whole video
most likely I haven't seen the whole
thing just maybe a few minutes this
throughout the whole video is probably
just gonna dismiss everything he didn't
even quote the argument by the way he
didn't say he quoted this passage and
this passage this was the point and it's
wrong he didn't even quote it he just
said they said there's a contradiction
of course they're wrong it's definitely
been dealt with before
would he allow some you know left Winger
to make the same argument
um Muslim to make the same argument
against him
I find it very very
intellectually dishonest and lazy from
being from being clearly honest
y take on this counselor
oh pass bro
all right guys you've heard it here
first Miss Milos go back to the Stream
but let's say you know nothing about
Christianity
and somebody says oh look here's the
contradiction
do you say to yourself wow I guess they
never noticed that
an apparent contradiction something that
seems on its face contradictory I guess
they either didn't notice that don't
care about that unaware of it
I mean does that even make sense
Christianity's been around for 2 000
years
they've reprinted the Bible billions of
times some of the most intelligent
people in the history of the world have
been Christians and Bible scholars so
well just just with common sense just
understanding all of that is basic
Common Sense do you think that all these
people you think that these institutions
these doctors scientists so on
philosophers
for thousands of years
you think that they didn't know about
these things you think that they didn't
have a way to make sense out of them do
you think that uh if they didn't know
about them or make sense out of them
that then they would try to correct
those things because once they say that
the Bible has been mistranslated they
say that the Bible has been
mistranslated or corrupted okay so if
the Bible's corrupted and if the if the
Christians are wrong why wouldn't they
just cover those things up
that's exactly what they tried to do I
don't get it that's exactly what they
tried to do there's there are 30 plus
gospels at the Council of nicaea in the
year 325 or whatever that took place
they only they only use four
where's the Gospel of Thomas the infancy
Gospel of Barnabas where are these
gospels the Gospel of Mary
eradicated because they disagreed with
them
or where are all the other letters of
Paul and and Luke the Evangelist and all
the other letters are written by these
people where are they they don't exist
and this is what I find so funny about
Nick florentes like he's he's genuinely
and he admits at the beginning but then
he pretends to know what he's talking
about which is a bit sad he says you
know I I wish I you know knew more about
uh you know Theology and Christianity so
and I quote shut these Muslims mouths
that's what he wants to do once he
learns more about Christianity he wants
to shut these Muslims mouths
and he clearly knows nothing like just
just look at this argument he's using
these some of the the best most
intellectual people came from
Christianity Christian Origins Christian
upbringing Christian nations
Europe was a disaster both East and West
Eastern Orthodox Western Catholic I
believe I got that right they were a
mess they were actually at war with each
other they were societally regressed
that's why they call it the Dark Ages
you know what save them from the Dark
Ages the Golden Age of Islam yes the
Golden Age of Islam people like Evan
Cena which to be fair he had some things
that might have taken him out of the
fold of Islam but definitely influenced
by Islam and Muslims and his his Nation
Pete you know the I I forget the name
but the one who created
um al-jabbar which is algebra math
science philosophy a lot of these things
began or were expanded greatly by the
Muslims and then Europe took these works
from the Muslims translated them from
Arabic into Latin read all of it studied
all of it
and then they adopted it to make their
own way of life and you know what
happened when they did that same thing
with the Bible when people when they
invented the printing press and they
were able to read the Bible
people like Martin Luther who was a
church father I'm not talking about
Martin Luther King the social activist a
Christian Church father when he read the
Bible he's like all these things the
church is preaching is not in here man
why am I going to obey this why am I
gonna listen to these people they used
to make people pay
for forgiveness literally they pay money
I swear I forgot what it's called I'm
trying to If someone knows what it's
called please type in this is like the
more money you pay the more sins that
are forgiven bro I I think so it's
something along those lines but yeah
they used to make them pay for
forgiveness it starts with an ire and
asked I forgot what it is but it was
there is a term for it but it's not in
the Bible obviously the Trinity's not in
the Bible so these are things that
people looked at and they're like I I
can't listen to the church anymore and
then they revolted and then liberalism
came from it the same thing he's
fighting liberalism in this Progressive
mindset came from
the church oppressing the people and
them revolting let me let me play
Devil's Advocate then bro and those
those amazing robotics for that let's
assume that somebody makes a same
equivalent argument that how are you
going to base an entire religion I.E
Christianity off of people that let's
say misrepresent or misunderstand the
Bible they misunderstand or misinterpret
the Bible you got the church doing one
thing you got most most Christians doing
one thing you got these weird you know
repentance practices with money that's
deviant from the actual teachings that's
one thing but it's not related to
Christianity the same way that they say
that a lot of Muslims don't represent
Islam so what would you say to that well
firstly the reason I'm making this
argument is because he's the one who
brought it up he said some of the best
people came from uh you know
Christianity or whatever or Christian
backgrounds so using his own logic is
what I was doing to review him but even
if someone you know said use that kind
of argument that you know they don't
represent Christianity okay who does
we're talking about the Roman Catholic
pope if he doesn't represent
Christianity which by the way
Catholicism is the the majority of all
Christians or I guess I could I should
say the largest denomination
so if they don't represent it who
doesn't Protestants well same thing with
them
so if not them who who then the
unitarians maybe they're the closest
that's that's the argument we're
returning you have no such thing in
Islam you have majority of of the ummah
they agree on the the fundamental
creatable aspects they don't disagree on
basic things like if God is one or not
or how God is one or how he isn't one
um hope that makes sense and by the way
someone put it in the chat is called
Indulgence that's what it's called when
you basically pay for your forgiveness
actual money to the church
if there wasn't a good reason for them
if there wasn't a good if there wasn't a
good explanation for those apparent
discrepancies
and if you're already accusing them of
being corrupt you know they've got no
Hang-Ups about
reproducing a corrupt text or corrupt
translation or something like this
then why wouldn't they just cover it up
why wouldn't they just when they notice
it just change it so that it's
consistent
so that would lead you to believe again
just based on common sense
that Christians are aware of it and have
a good reason for that that's why it's
still in there they want to maintain the
Integrity of the text
and so therefore and and that's not an
argument that those things don't need to
be explained I mean if again if you know
nothing and there is an apparent
discrepancy you would want an
explanation but the discrepancy is not
enough on its face to say oh there it is
like you said Christianity is not true
you know and that just goes to show I
don't think snico's really even
interested in this stuff I don't think
he's even curious
I think and and we have to get to the
bottom line here we got to get to the
fundamentals which is these red pill
people are really not interested all
that much in finding God
and that's one heck of a claim I think
that's one of the most egregious claims
he's made thus far because not only he's
attacking what I would say is his
friend's integrity
but it's very it's literally he could
just look a few months into the past
he'll see that sneako debated red pill
he basically denounced it he debated
against it we're on a stream saying you
know disagreeing about Poland he was
very fair about it as well
um so to say he doesn't care or he's not
really let's be honest what gets him
more views a crazy half I don't want to
say the word to get demonetized but I'll
say
ethnically biased
um stream with zerka or a stream of
sharehold member of the sitting talking
about religion which would actually get
more views in your eyes
so if he's all about views and you know
like well the reason would he be doing
it for if he's not interested in it
um that is fair bro
doing this lifestyle thing
and insofar as Islam comports with their
political lifestyle agenda then they
like Islam because when you listen to
their complaints about Christianity are
the reasons why they like Islam they
don't say things like I had a religious
experience they don't say things like uh
I I thought it was more convincing you
know that Islam's argument for the
nature of God is more convincing than
the Christian that is literally exactly
what sneako said almost verbatim
actually unless I misunderstood Nick
here but I don't know they say things
like well Islam's more based Islam is
more based and Christianity is more
French and in Islam you can have
multiple lives and in Islam they've the
Muslims
there's no in Islam Islam okay there's
no in Islam you can have multiple wise
bro you could have multiple women period
bro you want to live your life the way
you want to live your life
ain't nobody's stopping you bro you
wanna have 10 women you want to have 20
women be my guest Islam comes in to put
a limitation of four women that are not
only just there like how red pill
believes in like a rotation they're
women that are wives meaning you are
responsible in the eyes of Allah
and the state to take care of them you
have authority and responsibility but
you have accountability as well so it's
not like you could just have four women
just at your disposal bro the way that
he's making it sound
yeah absolutely but then the question is
what if he what if he responds by saying
that it's a scam or religion
because we're all like you know
marketers we basically we're Tradesmen
and we're just selling our religion
I mean amen all I can say Islam at the
end of the day bro we gotta understand
that when it comes to a man's natural
inclination right
it's not a matter of
is monogamy natural is polygyny natural
can men be faithful can they not be
faithful are they more promiscuous and
by promiscuity I mean
not just casual yeah and when it comes
into this whole idea of a man being with
multiple women nowhere in Islam does it
say you have to have multiple women
and Nora and Islam doesn't say you have
to have one wife
in the Bible I'm gonna pull a shake with
man your Bible you know it says that
your Bible Nick that same Bible tell me
how many wives Solomon had
like that same Bible talks about
polygyny the the Christian tradition has
monogamy and polygyny there's nothing
wrong with that modernity liberalism
tells you that there's something wrong
with polygeny
but yet practicing unrestricted
unmarital polygyny and polyamory is okay
like what
yeah that's a great Point that's a great
you'll see liberals having this thing
called a throuple where it's like two
guys and one girl or two girls and one
guy and obviously sometimes you know
today they can swing the same way it
could be like oh three girls or three
guys are stuck for Allah but as soon as
you say you know what I want to take
accountability God level accountability
and responsibility and I want to have a
family with them all of a sudden that's
an issue but uh a woman let's say having
20 Partners or a man having 20 Partners
that's okay
like do do they not see the level of
their argumentation it's just so
pathetic
yeah and you know what's so funny on top
of all that
Nick Fuentes has been on the record
basically praising the um I don't want
to say the name but it's whoever's in
power in Afghanistan right now
rhymes with taldi Fenn
he praised them and called them based
like and now he's coming around to say
all these red pillars all they do is say
Islam is based that's why I practice it
when he said the same thing because they
adopted some practices that apparently
he agrees with whatever those were
bro let's go back into it
and it's like really
so because
you don't think that Christians are
faithful enough to their religion and
Muslims are more faithful to their
religion you think the Muslim religion
is more true because the people believe
it harder
really so I guess Scientology is really
true because man against everything they
really believe it and I guess uh
Heaven's Gate man those guys the heavens
gate must be true because they all kill
themselves you know or the Jonestown
cult man those guys were the that was
the truest religion ever because they
really believed that they all kill
themselves
I mean there there's your fallacy right
there
it's so funny hearing this guy talk
about fallacies I don't think we're
gonna watch it for 15 minutes I think
that a lot of it's spoken enough for
itself is this that ass a real news
anchor show no like he has a cup and
everything
I hope not man I mean I got a cup here I
don't have a suit but I have a very
interesting alhamdulillah I don't know
maybe I could be a news anchor too what
do you guys think Rami news
bro I like Romney reacts better bro
but in all seriousness like I was
reflecting on his eye on the Quran where
Allah says never will they
let you basically never will they be
satisfied never will they be pleased the
disbelievers or the Christians until you
follow them in their disbelief or
misguidance depending on what
interpretation you want to use
so I'm thinking about this and I'm like
there's many and here's the thing we as
Muslims we can never keep people from
accepting Islam so it's not up to us to
be concerned about some other man's he
saw or anything like that we got to be
concerned about ourselves and on top of
that we don't make takfir We're not
gonna say you know what this person is
never going to get that princess never
gonna get the hidayah however
there's genuinely people that have
proven themselves Time and Time and
Again
David wood that these people know Islam
very well but they will still choose to
disbelieve and disobey Allah so my point
here is many people like these
individuals that I mentioned and may
Allah forgive me if I'm wrong because
again I still want them to get if it's
possible at this rate but people like
Nick Fuentes people like these these
YouTubers that are very islamophobic
they just despise The Deen of Allah
if these men ever get to a point where
they accept Islam alhamdulillah but if
they don't
never will they be satisfied unless we
leave Islam and the thing is we can't
leave Islam so we can't we can't ever
forsake the Deen of Islam and sneako if
you're watching this bro I get it you
accepted Islam alhamdulillah very
recently your new Muslim your new River
we've been watching your videos doing
Street Dao with shake with man giving
Dao on other streams another podcast
whether it's virtual or in person and
you just gotta keep going bro and to any
revert that accepted Islam just keep
going do more research if you have
doubts or anything like that reach out
to us but these people these these it
could be family members it could be
YouTubers Nick Fuentes whatever they'll
never be satisfied with you until you
join them it's not about who's right
who's wrong because a lot of them
clearly know that they're wrong but they
would rather
make the mistake of Iblis which is
knowing that you're wrong take many
people with you misguide as many people
as they can with them and it's not about
them ever coming to terms and accepting
it but it's like if I'm gonna go down
anyway let me take as many people as I
can with me
yeah and it's it's upon a lot it's crazy
you know and you quoted one eye from the
Quran Allah he mentions it throughout
the Quran the state of these people and
what they really want and who they
really are you know
that these people they they bite the
tips of their fingers in anger towards
the process you know that's how angry
they are
and Allah says that they can perish in
their anger you know they can basically
die in their anger like who cares
can you imagine being that person now
God says it about you
and then look at how Allah you know
talked about the Believers you know that
they're gonna have an amazing reward in
the afterlife that Allah you know Allah
is pleased with them what do you want
your lord your creator the creator of
the universe to speak about you in this
way and not in that former way
hmm
so I know bro I got a question for you
because you're a weaver yourself have
you had an experience coming into Islam
and reading the Quran for the first time
where you found the descriptions of
Allah
kind of wrathful in the sense that when
he mentions these things that the fate
of the disbelievers the fate of the
Hypocrites the fate of those that
willingly reject the signs did you ever
find that it was perhaps too harsh or
anything like that because a lot of
people that are let's say islamophobes
they use this argument that oh why is
your god so wrathful why is your god out
to just you know be
almost having human-like emotions and
this is an argument that I want us to
unpack but have you had that experience
bro coming into Islam
no I found it very unjust
because it's like a parent
who when their child acts up
they punish the child
you have a parent who the child acts up
and they don't punish the child or they
even reward the child
yeah look how that child ends up in the
future
and this is a simple example and to
compare God to our parents is is not
befitting but it's a simple example just
to put it all into perspective
you know before the question is getting
excited about the father and the son
analogy that's not what we're saying but
I love you analogy because it's it's
kind of like when you do have a parent
and I do want you guys to bear with us
we're not making an analogy like a
parent and a child or anything like that
but in the same parental love in the
sense that it's almost Tough Love
sometimes it's like if you love your kid
too much to the point where you don't
enforce the parameters and the lines
very firm you don't know where they're
going to end up but you're not doing it
because you hate them you're doing it
because you love them it's just I feel
many people today especially uh in this
post-modern Society this lip tart
Society they get way too caught up in
this idea that love from God should be
almost like
anthropomorphized love from like human
beings the way that we love God should
love the way we're inclusive and all
whatever we we have tolerance for
everything we stand for nothing like
Tate says God should be like that too
and our forgiveness should be like God's
forgiveness but why does that have to be
the case who said that the emotions that
we have are going to be the ways that
Allah operates no one like this
presupposition itself is knowledge
invalid to to have this notion that God
should forgive the way that we forgive
or God should think that the way that we
think that makes Islam if that was the
case it would be no different than all
other religions where man makes God In
His Image in his Perceptions in the way
that he perceives a God to be just just
like the way he perceives man to be and
then he projects these attributes into
their God or goddesses or deities or
whatever they worship but in Islam Allah
himself tells us who he is what he is
and it's from that that we understand
God not leaving you know man to
rationalize or philosophize what God
should be like yeah that's an amazing
point and and it's crazy because you'll
find people like I heard this recently
circus said on stinkle stream he's like
you know what's the ultimate form of
love you know and he's like you know
sacrificing yourself for someone that's
the ultimate form of love you basically
you give up you pass away you know so
that's why our God is better and it's
like you can only sacrifice yourself if
you are susceptible to death if you are
mortal
and if you're Immortal then a sacrifice
would be meaningless because you
couldn't be sacrificed to begin with and
and that's why I think Christianity
really ultimately fails because I I
understand they're trying to make an
emotional tug you know that's why they
call it the passion narrative as far as
I know they call it the passion
narrative because it's very passionate
it's very pulling it really intrigues
the person and brings them in and and
almost you know to a tearful because
they're like wow God died for me
but when you think about it doesn't make
sense because if God is immoral Immortal
how could he die and if he did then it
would be meaningless because he could
never die to begin with
so that's why I think our conception of
God that's why I know our conception of
God is far better because it's actually
God
God is the almighty and he stays the
almighty he's after a living he stays
ever living he's all knowledgeable he
stays all knowledgeable he doesn't come
down as a man and forget
which God would be better do you want do
you want a God that can die or an
almighty God who is not susceptible to a
thing if you had a bodyguard would you
want a bodyguard that could pass away or
a bodyguard that could not be
susceptible to a damn thing
it reminds me what you just said ties
into my point like seamlessly bro
effortlessly because my point was man
has made the mistake of projecting God
In His Image
and if you look at Christianity it's
almost like we as human beings it's part
of our fitra to worship Allah it's also
part of our fitra to repent so when you
look at that it's almost like man
Christianity it created this God in
their image and with their attributes of
wanting to seek repentance and that's
how you get their perception of Jesus
coming as a son from the father to die
for the sins almost like to repent as an
act of here's what I'm gonna do and now
everything's gonna be okay now there's
going to be Justice whereas okay you got
some of it right which is the fact that
we as human beings do need to repent but
God himself does not need to do that God
is independent if God needs that then
God himself is dependent on something
that is a limitation that's no longer
God then that's a human being
exactly 100 and I think that's an
amazing point before we continue I do
want to say uh some people said to
continue the video
um so I guess we'll take a vote in the
chat if you guys want us to continue
just say yes if not say no or say
continue don't continue it's up to you
but um if you continue the video I'm
gonna I'm Gonna Leave the Stream
okay
I mean you're afraid to do that come on
bro
okay what's the verdict chat they're
coming in Fairly slowly
so
oh God okay yes do not yes yes yes no no
yes no no no no no no I don't know if I
said no twice for one person yes it
seems like 50 50. okay there's more no's
yeah it looks like there's more no's
than yes and I don't know if people are
are voting twice it looks like people
are so I guess we're just
oh God someone spam finish the video
um I don't know man
yeah
I will still continue yeah honestly
continue the video there's not gonna be
much new unless there are some arguments
that you won't unpack the videos you
haven't watched this have you yeah I
haven't so I I can't really say if
there's a there's value to it you guys
come on we we keep it real over here at
T3 and we don't pre-watch reaction
videos what type of reaction would that
be do a poll I don't know if we can do a
poll to be honest I don't know how to at
least but regardless there is another
video I want to share so maybe this will
satisfy some people inshallah do it and
I think it's only fitting to be honest
so the whole time he's basically
knocking
Remy
salaam well no I'm playing
we're not about to end this stream
because around me had technical
difficulties it does say he's uh
he's spinning though you see that on the
bottom left
no it just says speaker offline
speaker offline no bro look at the
look at the preview on the studio I'm
looking at it right now yeah you see
that thing's spinning next to shahab son
do you even see a screen yeah I see it
okay let me let me remove him from from
the scene
until he's back oh he's he's not even
here okay guys inshallah until around me
comes back we are going to be doing a
little bit of
a reflection on either other
so
I believe this is your second if not
third Eid
how was it
Allah
were you with uh your immediate family
I was by myself
may Allah bless you I do want to take
this moment to give a quick reminder to
everybody that if you have a Reaver in
the community or reverts in the
community they don't have Muslim backing
corporate backing come on no they don't
have a whole team of Muslims just ready
pulling up at 6 a.m with sweets and
buckle of us taking them to the Masjid
for Salah they don't have that
unfortunately so it's up to us to be the
community for them and I get it Eid was
done yesterday
but it wasn't it started yesterday
there's three days of Eid it's not too
late reach out to those rivers in your
community invite them on to your house
or on a gathering or an outing or
something and next either make sure you
guys plan this accordingly because at
the end of the day as Muslims if we
don't have Community shaytan comes for
the lone believer
at the same time though I do want to say
alhamdulillah being alone is still
better than bad company so at least you
were by yourself